я хочу ви слова ти свою паладинську по
глядачеві немов зуміли козара забуваєте про
прокуратурі в хату ми з поділася ще
за
відвар про нього нам
все буде шуму оон і бачимо що шанувати іди
і ким би ви раніше за
володар було б все ворони продовжилося
будь я прийшов у протестувати і порти
системі постійно століття дозволяючи їм
прокуратурі доливу кінного так оральну
функцію помітно огляду вояка та прописано
у конституції це без карнизу по будова
на генеральній прокуратурі можливо
вимагатиме за користувачами агінського suspense
твій стан змін мій українець
навколишні на блюдце та довжини на 1 рівні
кеди puma ж нам по брата корупції в
україні та традиції сюди і хто хоче
реально хочеш з орбіти хто хоче пройти
цю систему ще петри менталітету
буває нас тут на єдиний державний орган
річці ясна бореться з корупцією ціна бу
і ціна ставить бійці види на правах шкоди
це сьогодні у годину cool їм для чого
видно лінію олігархічну консенсусу та
фактично наступна все києву
демократичні сили ми поважаємо за
необхідно бідного